Si tuviéramos que encontrar una muestra pura
de hidrógeno, lo más probable es que sus átomos
individuales no estén flotando separados por ahí,
sino que la mayoría de ellos, si no es que todos,
estarán unidos formando lo que se conoce como
hidrógeno diatómico, que representamos como H₂.
Otra forma de representarlo es uniendo los átomos
del hidrógeno diatómico por un enlace para formar
una molécula diatómica como esta, una molécula
que sólo está hecha de dos átomos de hidrógeno.
Y por esto tiene sentido que sea estable, ya
que cada uno de los átomos individuales de
hidrógeno tiene 1 electrón de valencia en su
estado neutro, y si comparten sus electrones
de valencia, ambos pueden sentir que tienen
completa su capa más externa, por lo tanto,
esta raya representa un par de electrones que
se comparten en un enlace covalente. Ahora,
lo que vamos a hacer en este video es pensar
en la distancia entre los átomos. Como ejemplo,
imaginemos 2 hidrógenos de esta forma. Aquí
tenemos un átomo de hidrógeno y por acá otro átomo
de hidrógeno. Resulta que a temperatura y presión
estándar la distancia entre los centros de los
átomos es aproximadamente igual a 74 picómetros.
Y recordemos qué tan pequeño es un picómetro:
un picómetro es la billonésima parte de 1 metro.
Así que estas son 74 billonésimas partes de metro,
es decir, estamos hablando de distancias muy
pequeñas. Y una pregunta interesante sería:
¿por qué es esta la distancia?, ¿qué pasaría si
intentáramos comprimirlos más?, o ¿qué pasaría
si intentamos separarlos? Para pensar en esto,
haremos una pequeña gráfica que compara la energía
potencial y la distancia. En el eje vertical
pondremos la energía potencial, y todavía no
daré las unidades, sólo lo pensaremos en términos
conceptuales muy generales, podremos pensar en
las unidades en un momento. Por acá tenemos la
distancia entre los centros atómicos: podemos ver
esto como la distancia entre los núcleos, y esta
distancia la daremos en picómetros. Ahora bien,
si lo pensamos, la energía potencial debe de
ser relativa a algo más, así que, de manera
arbitraria, digamos que a una distancia de 74
picómetros nuestra energía potencial está por
aquí, aunque no vamos a etiquetar este eje aún.
Ahora, ¿qué le pasará a la energía potencial si
quisiéramos alejar estos dos átomos? Bueno, esta
es la distancia típica a la que se encuentran,
así que probablemente sea un punto bajo en la
energía potencial. Si hacemos que se alejen,
entonces añadiremos energía, lo que hará que la
energía potencial aumente. Para que esto tenga más
sentido, imagina un resorte por aquí. Si queremos
alargarlo, es decir, si jalamos cada uno de los
extremos del resorte, estamos añadiendo energía,
lo que aumenta la energía potencial, ya que si lo
soltamos se acelerarán de regreso un extremo hacia
el otro. Por lo tanto, a medida que alejamos los
núcleos agregamos energía potencial; al tener
distancias cada vez mayores entre los núcleos
aumenta la energía potencial. Y si lo llevamos
realmente lejos tenderemos hacia una asíntota
en cierto valor, y ese valor será la energía
potencial si estos dos átomos no estuvieran
enlazados de ninguna forma, si ellos, en cierto
punto, no estuvieran relacionados entre sí, es
decir, si no interactuaran. Y este es el punto que
la mayoría de los químicos y físicos o científicos
marcarían como energía potencial 0, es decir, la
energía en la que están infinitamente lejos uno
del otro. Y este es el valor de la asíntota a la
que tenemos; así que dibujemos nuestra asíntota
y llamémosla cero. De hecho, es buen momento de
poner unidades. Vamos a decir que esto está dado
en Kilos Jules por mol. Una vez más, al alejarnos
a medida que se separan más y más, nos acercamos
más y más a esta asíntota, es decir, a que los
átomos no interactúen. ¿Por qué pasa esto? Porque
entre más y más y más los alejes, las fuerzas
de Coulomb entre ellos serán cada vez más y más
y más débiles. Es por esta razón que les gusta
considerarla como la energía potencial 0. Bien,
¿qué pasa si pensamos en el caso contrario?,
¿qué pasará si queremos acercarlos más? Bueno,
otra vez pensemos en un resorte. Si imaginas
un resorte como este, de la misma manera que
necesitas añadir o aumentar la energía potencial
del resorte para alargarlo o separar sus extremos,
también necesitarás aplicar energía para
comprimirlo un poco más. Por lo tanto,
para que estos dos átomos estén cada vez más
cerca, tendremos que añadir energía al sistema
y aumentar la energía potencial. ¿Y por qué
tenemos que agregar más energía al sistema?
Bueno, porque entre más se presionen estos dos
núcleos, sus cargas positivas se van a repeler y,
por lo tanto, tendremos que superar esa fuerza,
lo que agregará energía potencial al sistema;
mientras que los electrones van a empezar
a traslaparse entre ellos y, por lo tanto,
también se van a repeler. Entonces, lo que
acabamos de esbozar, de manera conceptual,
es la idea de que si queremos que realmente se
traslapen entre sí, entonces vamos a tener una
energía potencial muy grande. Y la idea de que
si queremos que se separen demasiado entre sí,
no tendremos una energía potencial tan grande,
pero será mayor a la que tendríamos en este punto
estable. El punto estable es estable porque es un
punto mínimo, es el punto más bajo de esta gráfica
de energía potencial. Podrías verlo como correcto,
y resulta que, para un hidrógeno diatómico esta
diferencia entre 0 y el punto donde lo encontramos
a presión y temperatura estándar, esta distancia
que tenemos aquí, es de 432 KJ/mol, así que aquí
estamos en el punto -432 KJ/mol. Así que una
cosa interesante que podemos preguntarnos en un
diagrama como este es: ¿cuánta energía necesitamos
para separar estos dos átomos, es decir, para
romper por completo este enlace? Bueno, sería
la energía requerida para separarlos por completo,
así que será esta energía que tenemos aquí o 432
KJ. A esto se le conoce como energía de enlace, es
decir, la energía que se requiere para separar los
átomos. Y en videos futuros veremos que cuanto más
pequeños son los átomos individuales y mayor sea
el orden de los enlaces, de un enlace simple
a un enlace doble a un enlace triple, cuanto
mayor sea el orden de los enlaces mayor será la
energía de enlace con la que vamos a trabajar.